so the first one is from marcus uh the
question is do i have any concerns about
upper limits for soy intake
um do i have any issues with getting you
know a pretty substantial amount of your
your protein coming from soy and the
question asks you know up to like 1.6 or
2.2 grams per kilogram all coming from
soy protein
usually when people ask this question
they have
two concerns that are somewhat related
the first concern
is about the potentially estrogenic side
effects uh related to soy isoflavones
uh and then people wonder you know is
there potentially going to be some kind
of like feminizing impact from uh from
this estrogenic stuff and then
secondarily
and then the second uh opposite concern
is of course
will it make my dick too hard correct
yeah the secondary concern related to
that is will it impact
hypertrophy yeah
that never mind sorry uh so anyway uh
it's a question that comes up a lot and
what's really interesting my whole body
too turgid
correct
the thing that is interesting about this
is that i see a lot of answers that are
extremely definitive one way or the
other and i kind of
uh
aim for the middle ground a little bit
so here's what i can say and i'll post
some links in the description of today's
show
great study by our friend cody hahn
who's a stronger by science coach uh he
did a ton of really great work uh when
he was working on his phd
out at uh at auburn their lab does some
really fascinating stuff but
they're looking at different types of
protein supplementation and in this case
i think the the title kind of gives it
away the paper is called soy protein
supplementation is not androgenic or
estrogenic in college-aged men when
combined with resistance exercise
training so even at doses up to about 80
grams per day of soy protein uh they did
not observe any estrogenic effects uh
that would be physiologically meaningful
uh there's also a meta-analysis of 15
randomized controlled trials that i'm
aware of indicating that uh soy protein
supplementation had no significant
effect on total testosterone free
testosterone
or sex hormone blind binding globulin
and within those rcts uh the the the soy
protein content was typically between 10
and 70 grams of soy protein
and the isoflavone content which is what
people are largely focused on
was between like 60 to 240 milligrams
so based on that a lot of people say
there's absolutely no connection there
uh under no circumstance could there be
a concern or or uh should it be a
consideration whatsoever i'm not quite
prepared to go that far just because
like we've talked about this in various
places but i tend to be more of an
empiricist uh you know i i like
empirical arguments more than trying to
rationalize my way to an argument so
when i can lean on empirical data i much
prefer to i feel more comfortable with
it
um
so i feel very extremely comfortable
that with doses up to like 80 grams a
day of soy protein i really don't have
concerns especially if the isoflavone
content of that soy protein product is
staying within that range i mentioned
uh there are a couple case studies that
have been published case studies you
take them with a grain of salt but uh
you know people who are consuming up to
like
360 milligrams of soy isoflavones per
day for like six to twelve months at a
time where uh they have noted some
adverse effects uh that that
could be considered a bit estrogenic in
nature uh or kind of linked to these
estrogenic concerns so um
there are case studies out there uh and
you can put whatever stock you want into
those but uh
up to like 80 grams a day i feel
extremely confident uh and then when it
comes to the hypertrophy stuff
i mentioned that that study previously
looking at hypertrophy over the course
of a
12-week resistance training program
the the
vegan group who was supplementing with
soy protein
had extremely similar uh training
adaptations in terms of hypertrophy so
leg lean mass whole muscle
cross-sectional area muscle fiber
cross-sectional area strength
all those training adaptations were
quite similar and they were getting 0.8
grams per kilogram per day
purely from soy protein
it did just based on their weights i
think it ended up being like 57 or 58
grams a day
so just from an empirical perspective i
feel extremely comfortable you know that
up to 80 grams a day or you know up to
like half of your protein for the day
coming purely from soy uh simply doesn't
seem to be an issue for any of any
concerns within this kind of umbrella of
topics
uh when you start doubling those numbers
i simply don't know i don't know if you
have a strong opinion on that but
um
i like to be
more
guided by empirical evidence when
possible and this just kind of seems to
be
where it ends in controlled trials is
with doses up around 80 grams a day
here's what i have a strong opinion
about so
a couple of times friends have come over
and i've been making little treats
[Music]
you know the story you were here
um so
making some little treats
like uh like
fried chicken either chicken wings or
like little uh
like popcorn chicken or whatever
and then for vegetarian and vegan
friends some uh
similarly either battered or breaded and
fried and then sauced soy puffs yes and
i gotta say
this is coming from a completely
inveterate omnivore that loves meat i
like it it's good the [ __ ] fried soy
puffs are are better than every other
meat option that has been available
every time that i've
uh like prepared and fried and sauced
the same thing like yeah uh the the soy
puffs beat out chicken
uh they beat out like i made some just
insane fried meatballs but then also
made some fried soy puffs the [ __ ]
soy puffs were better i gotta say man
culinarily they're
they're incredible because they're just
like
they're puffs there's a lot of air in
them they can soak up any flavor
uh they have an excellent texture and
mouth feel so um
yeah
my only strong opinion about soy is that
if you're
if you're an omnivore and you're a
foodie and
you have some vegetarian or vegan
friends coming over and you're like ah
like i don't know
what sort of of meat substitute or meat
alternative to have if you were going to
make a little a little fried treat uh
just just using whatever recipe you were
going to use otherwise but subbing in
whatever meat option you were going to
have for soy puffs swear to god best
decision you'll ever make and you will
probably also like the soy puffs better
than than the meat option they're
they're so good they're incredible you
know another time that happened uh
there have been some cases where you've
made uh a mushroom based version of
something uh as opposed to a meat-based
version there have been instances where
the mushroom version is better mushrooms
are also very good mushrooms are very
good so i think a lot of people when
they consider
uh you know incorporating more
vegetarian meals they're like well i
have officially departed from flavor
town and i can never go back
and that's really not the case uh
there's some really nice options but
uh just to kind of put a little anecdote
on top of this uh
you know i still consume whey protein
for i believe reasons we've discussed on
the podcast like i think uh from a
ethical and environmental standard
viewpoint it kind of fits within my
uh
i'm comfortable with it from from those
perspectives just because
a lot of the way that goes into whey
protein powder seems to be
essentially just a byproduct of
conventional dairy food production that
they're they're just going to kind of
get rid of either way
so i don't lose a lot of sleep over
having a lot of protein coming from whey
protein supplements but i do eat a lot
of soy protein coming from things like
soy crumbles that's my main source of
soy protein that i get often
have i ever
once counted how many grams i'm getting
from soy absolutely not
uh so i i try to separate out like from
a purely empirical point of view there
are case reports trending in that
direction with extremely high intakes
and very well controlled trials showing
no such effect up to about 80 grams a
day would i start getting nervous if i
had 100 grams a day coming from soy
products
i definitely wouldn't uh i'm pretty
comfortable that
unless you have a truly anomalous intake
of soy
you're probably not going to run into
these types of concerns that that would
be my my estimation but to make that
estimation you do have to deviate from
the empirical evidence a little bit